لكن في كاليفورنيا ، الرجل الذي اخترع واحدة من أولى السيارات ذاتية القيادة هو في الواقع يضع نصب عينيه
أعلى قليلاً بعد أن
أمضى ساعات طويلة من حياتي في
سيارة ذاتية القيادة عادة ما تكون عالقة في
حركة المرور ، أدركت حتى لو نجحت في
بناء الذات المثالية  -
ستظل السيارة عالقة في حركة المرور
ثم تنظر إلى السماء
وتدرك رائعًا أنه لا يوجد شيء هناك
مثل السماء فارغة دائمًا ،
غالبًا ما يتم الترحيب بسيباستيان باعتباره
الأب الروحي وليس بالضرورة
الآباء المؤسسين  تدور أحداثه حول
السيارات ذاتية القيادة أيضًا
[موسيقى]
أصبحت سيارته ذاتية القيادة أول من
يفوز بإحدى الجوائز البحثية المرموقة في أمريكا
وأصبح خبيرًا مشهورًا عالميًا في
هذا الموضوع الآن
أعتقد أن هناك رؤية هنا
لتكنولوجيا جديدة وأنا  أتطلع حقًا
إلى وقت
تنظر فيه الأجيال بعدنا إلى الوراء
وتقول كم كان الأمر سخيفًا
بالنسبة لقيادة البشر للسيارات ، ولكن سرعان ما غيّر
التروس ،
فنحن نريد ابتكار سيارة طائرة سيكون
الأمر كذلك
أسهل بكثير إذا كنت تستطيع رفع نفسك
قليلًا على تلك الأقدام وتكون بعيدًا
عن كل شيء ،
ثم يمكنك السير في خط مستقيم
، ولا توجد عوائق يمكن أن تكون
أكثر أمانًا مما ستكون عليه السيارات في أي وقت مضى ،
لذلك أصبح من الواضح أنه يجب علي  العمل
على شركة سيباستيان هذه ، تعمل
كيتي هوك الآن بجد على
جانب طائرة كهربائية ذاتية القيادة ذات مقعد واحد ،
هذا الشيء يطير
بسرعة ضعف سرعة السيارات
بنصف الطاقة ، مثل
طائرة بدون طيار لشخص واحد إذا أردت
، وتنطلق عموديًا  وهي تطير
بك إلى مدى يصل إلى حوالي 100 ميل بالإضافة إلى
الاحتياطيات ،
لذلك قمنا ببناء ما يقرب من 10
مركبات ثقيلة وقمنا باختبارها
وما زلنا في مرحلة النموذج الأولي ، تعمل
العديد من الشركات حول
العالم على السيارات الطائرة
ولكن سيباستيان يتصور باستخدامه
إنشاء نظام تاكسي جوي
، وتتمثل المهمة في تحرير العالم من
حركة المرور إذا كنت تريد أن
تقول ضعف حجم الطريق السريع ،
فماذا تفعل جيدًا ،
ستهدم الكثير من المنازل وتبني المزيد من
الأرصفة
إذا كنت  تريد مضاعفة الطرق السريعة
في السماء ، ما تفعله بإعادة تجميع
برامجك ،
لديك مسار جديد يبدو رائعًا
مثل العودة إلى المستقبل
الذي كان منذ 35 عامًا خيالًا علميًا
حيث نحن ذاهبون لسنا بحاجة إلى طرق ،
لذلك إذا كان لدينا  لن تحتاج المدن إلى طرق
ما سيحتاجون إليه